don't die okay I'll try
we're all gonna die instantly no no
trust me I'm I'm super good at this game
yeah I'm pretty pretty good too
sometimes I think I'm but I think I'm
better than you
well the other day and I can try on five
times he him Justin and doctor
disrespect boot camp it is
sorry we're not homosexual
we're just emanating yeah you dying once
we drop in a few seconds you're gay
don't say night I don't want to be
that's what a gay person all the same
keep crawling
okay hey stand still
what are you doing can you stand still
oh my god you ate sup Utes oh my god we
have to win now how do you know how do I
know how do you know we're you know oh
my I misread you my guy my bad I can see
the future
that's why are we gonna win I mean I
just said it what if we don't you pay
well it will happen all right don't
worry about it keep it just pick where
we're landing is that not your style
yeah that is how you win the game dude
this is the big brain stress that's
thinking outside the box yeah I like it
oh you know you're not you're not really
Feud no I just sound like him a lot no I
was kidding it's me now all right look
key though where would you be drawn I
don't think that's I'm serious this is
how we win come on man why don't you set
it down if I find you if you drop this
I'm dropping there I'm telling you right
now that's where the loot is I'm gonna
be like swimming across and down no no
there's two buildings we get one each
just really you pick which one do you
want
I already paint all right I got a health
pack that doesn't sound like the
essentials I think we both get ahead
King okay we gotta help packs dude
look at that refining ocean I tell you
this is the spot I told you this is the
strap don't lose this still esteem where
there's more people yeah he was not
right no you killed one guy okay you
tell me what you want you really really
want I really really want to know it's
just going through a bad Spice Girls
reference there but I guess that's way
too dated
can you sing one other than left tell me
what you want what you really really
want you know that was really good hey
are you in again I'd like to think so
I do auto cross racing when I'm not
wasting show me the flips
it's good you're good all right don't
die guys good tip I got more if you want
you got another tip for me Yeah right
why are you making dirty jokes
catch them fast man I don't like it all
right I thought this was a Christian
Church server yeah I'm gonna have to
report you then I won't report if you
promise not to make any more dirty jokes
okay Kenny even the report okay yeah
yeah yeah you can you can don't don't
threaten me do not do it dude this guy
has a machete dude
oh my god this is what you get for
swearing on a Christmas really oh look
at this one what is he doing what is he
doing don't kill him he's my Christian
slave so much better I get that a line
where are you from - China Sweden China
number one why you laughing that oh my
God look at all this epic loot I got now
many more tips no tips all right what is
it what do I can hear you
no no I heard it I said no that's not
what you say you say - not Christian
word and I'm playing in a Christian
server can you stop please okay I'm
sorry all right
you're forgiven I still have to report
you then you're a piece of trash garbage
hoping you're a bag of balls that no one
wants oh sure
alpha is too far come on come on all
right if I don't make it I'm gonna
report you
for what reason relying on reason my mom
works for this game I'm not joking you
gotta go around that mountain yeah I'm
not sure we can get the best of bounine
and then I yell aside we could make it I
trust yellow you're so bad
made it safe yellow what did I say I got
it - ah ah no no behind us don't worry
guys I'll save you
[Music]
I told you I'm Pro watch his solo dinner
you see this I have 500 kills other
people's kills I'm doing all the work
dude you're dead all right
you can't talk [ __ ] got real
I'm fine hey no I'm gonna have to report
you now
yeah this is a Christian server it was
like that was a dinosaur wait all right
that's the point of controversy let's
not mention those Christian oh my god oh
we got the main reporter back in oh yeah
did you see that Kerry lights game so I
got 5,000 kills but I died at the last
one oh nice
well you should have stayed I needed the
support I'm sorry
yeah I was busy reporting someone or
should we drive I don't know
I've got making choices come on man you
can do it
make a choice we will we will to go
there no I'm gonna head where Nordic
blade is going no suede his opinion it
was no sin to him no it was a
beautifully touching speech that he gave
and it really swayed my opinion it
changed my views
don't let him influence him come on man
be yourself a man you pick somewhere
else he's trying to sway you again don't
listen to him I was thinking like
paradise as divorce you ever heard don't
ever give your opinion again here and
you're an [ __ ] I'm sorry I'm just
joking are you kidding me Green do
something green [ __ ] oh oh oh you're
not doing anything green green come here
great